questions from the mailbag which means
we didn't have anything else to talk
about in this segment so we asked you
for ideas for content but we're
transparent about that as well we're
transparent about how we get our ideas
and colonoscopies teddy
at matt evan has a question what is more
likely for panthers for now quarterback
teddy bridgewater he remains the
panthers week one starter backs up sam
darnold or starts for a different team
at some point during the 2021 season
this one is probably the easiest
question we'll get all day well i mean
it's it's no no and no really is what i
would say you know i mean
okay maybe starts for a different team
at some point during the 2021 season
that's that's where i would say that's a
possibility but i mean i think you and
me are in the same camp here i don't
think there's any way he's in carolina i
i don't any as a starter a backup
whatever that may be that's gone it's
done with and then you know now it's a
different team and i i don't look at it
as a like oh he's gonna go to a
different team and be a starter unless
seattle maybe did something with russell
wilson and traded him that's the only
place i look at to just go definitive
starter you know yeah i maybe he gets a
chance to fairly compete against drew
lock and do all that but i would still
think even drew gets the edge there so
ultimately i think he's a backup for
another team who's just gonna wait for
his chance to maybe get to play in
2021 yeah i think of these options he's
not going to be the weak one starter in
carolina he's not going to back up
they're going to get rid of him because
it's 17 million if he's on the week one
roster it's only 10 million now he will
be cut if he's not traded and i think he
will be traded and the panthers will pay
part of the 10 million guaranteed that
he's already due to make i think the
most likely is he ends up starting at
some point later this year for another
team whether it's denver or whether it's
he becomes that gap quarterback in san
francisco dump garoppolo in the 25
million pay teddy 12 or so right let him
be the guy until mack jones trey lance
justin fields whoever is ready to go at
number three and then you don't have
that potential for a jimmy garoppolo if
he has that assignment to be great and
awesome and then it's impossible to pull
him off the field you want a guy that
even if you're four and one or five and
two or whatever the case may be if you
the other guy's ready you don't want it
to be a huge ruckus yeah that's what you
probably the starter for the young guy
which uh far less chance of a ruckus if
teddy bridgewater is the guy who'd get
pulled yeah agreed you're you're right
that would have to be the the type of
scenario there so yeah i think we're on
the same page with teddy b and where he
goes all right uh pft pm policy has a
question as it relates to deshaun watson
hindsight being 2020 should the texans
have taken the best trade offer weeks
ago for desean or is holding on to him
the better choice overall this is
another easy one i appreciate yeah go
ahead and do it these make us look like
we're not idiots yeah of course they
should have traded they should they
should have dumped him for whatever they
could have gotten before we became aware
of the first lawsuit period and they
should have moved on moved out taken
what they could and let someone else
deal with this mess the question i have
is because this was percolating from the
middle of february onward
would the new team
have found out through the exercise of
whatever due diligence would have been
performed before trading for deshaun
watson would they have caught wind yeah
right of this right and said no we're
not going to go forward thanks texans
but nah seem too anxious to trade this
guy all of a sudden we did our homework
we're we're not going to do this what
what like
i mean to me again yeah of course in
hindsight you know yeah they should have
traded them and all of that the only
thing you can really look at the texans
right now and just where you just go you
know
why were they being so stubborn i mean i
think like
where they messed up at least in my eyes
is not like really fairly evaluating
like the the temperature and the room
there really whereas like you and i know
we knew from a lot of different people
that watson wasn't playing for the
texans
and i understand you don't want to let
like players run the team and do all
those things but they made a number of
mistakes along the way too
so that's where i just look at it and go
like
why did you think you were going to be
able to salvage this situation it had
gotten to a point
and we knew
that it was just it was not salvageable
at that point so that's only where i can
really just like say okay that i don't
get about the texans but yeah i mean
again you know they were probably doing
due diligence on the draft and things
like that and you know driving up the
market making teams more desperate i
don't know i don't know what their
thought was in that or maybe they really
thought like we're not trading them and
we're not going to listen to his demands
i i i don't know
i think they were always going to trade
him or at least we're going to be
willing to trade him i go back to the
nick casario comments that were made
when they introduced david cully as the
new coach and i think the answer was
hiding in plain sight they didn't slam
the door on it it was just a question of
when they were going to decide to take
the phone calls when they were going to
decide to move toward
shopping deshaun watson they were
picking the right spot maybe it was
going to be leading up to the draft
maybe it would have happened now they
just didn't want to do it then if they'd
had any reason
to know and this creates some
interesting ethical questions and it
leads into our next question from tacos
and gin if deshaun watson were traded
four weeks ago could the deal have been
canceled after these allegations great
questions interesting ethical window
here yeah if the texans caught wind of
this
and dumped him
onto a team that didn't know
about it
what recourse if any would the new team
have had
against the texans now i believe that
the nfl
would not
have done anything about this the nfl's
attitude is
hey
you're on your own
you do your homework you've got security
people who work for you you've got ways
of finding things out if the texans knew
something and didn't disclose it
that's
they don't have an obligation to
disclose the possibility that there may
be a lawsuit or 22 of them that you know
they they they don't have to say that
that information is available to anyone
they happen to have it you don't i think
i think the deal would have gone through
and the deal would have remained now
would it have destroyed the relationship
between nick casario david cully and
anyone else with the team
that that took on deshaun watson not
knowing about this absolutely yeah would
it have potentially and here's the thing
it's not just whether or not you know
someone from the dolphins doesn't like
me now it's i've got mortal enemies in
brian flores and
and chris greer and you know
it it's a small industry
and paths cross all the time and
sometimes you need a job you don't want
to go around pissing people off sorry
london gratuitously because your career
at some point maybe that's why these
guys shall pull it so right yeah so i i
think that that uh
it would have been very ill advised for
the texans to have known about it and
unloaded deshaun watson to a team that
didn't know about it but either way
chris i don't think the nfl would have
done anything no well and then to that
point too like
the one thing that that does show a
little bit
is you know for all the conspiracies and
we're the texans in cahoots with busby
and all that like i would think if they
had a any inkling that something like
this was going down going they would
have traded them they would have been
like i don't know this guy there might
be some you know crap that hits the fan
here at some point in the next month two
half a year or whatever we'll get rid of
them so that that to me also just within
this kind of proves that at least i
don't think they had any clue that this
was going on with desean watson's
private life
apparently 50 years ago pete rozelle
avoided a trade between the cowboys and
the patriots dwayne thomas was traded to
new england he refused to report and
pete rozelle voided the trade
look i don't i just i don't see that
happening now
i i don't know what the grounds would be
oh the guy didn't show up i remember
when richard seymour was traded to the
raiders if at first he wasn't going to
show up well the raiders would have had
recourse
they trade for the guy and if he doesn't
show up you have recourse under the cba
remember when the broncos traded jake
plummer to the buccaneers and he retired
the buccaneers attacked the signing
bonus that they didn't even pay they
only got like three and a half million
out of jake plummer right who they had
never paid a cent to because they traded
for him and he didn't show up so i don't
think the nfl would do anything about
this uh because all's fair i think this
falls into the bucket of all's fair and
if you're willing if you're nick casario
to make an enemy for life by knowing
something and still going through with
the trade with someone who doesn't know
it that's on you because that is going
to stick with you a lot longer than the
aftermath of that trade at user for life
if deshawn watson is found guilty in a
civil trial can he be prosecuted at a
later date as long as the statute of
limitations hasn't run he they can go
forward with the civil case
and prosecutor can monitor it
prosecutors can decide to pursue charges
as long as they're within the statute of
limitations is that right for criminal
charges yeah usually for criminal
charges the statute is longer than it is
for civil charges look this is why every
once in a while you'll see somebody
who's sued
and when it's time for them to get
called to testify they invoke their
fifth amendment right against
self-incrimination because they'd rather
lose the civil case
than end up being prosecuted because of
how they get twisted in knots by
the plaintiff's lawyer who
cross-examines them in the civil case
that's one of the the things that that i
used as my basis for saying deshaun
watson needs to settle this case because
there's no there's no
good outcome to these civil cases if he
hasn't been prosecuted yeah
because then when it's time to testify
you got to ask yourself do i invoke the
fifth amendment
and basically forfeit
these lawsuits because how are you going
to win how you going to win
they the ashley solis tells her story
and then they called to sean watson
first question i invoke my right against
self-incrimination he's done it's over
it's over just fill out the verdict form
at that point right it's over just a
question how much money ashley solis
gets his compensation for her harm
and then if you do answer questions if
you waive your right against
self-incrimination
and you do get twisted in knots by tony
busby or someone else who prosecute who
who cross-examines aggressively then you
gotta worry about getting prosecuted
it's that that's all the more reason why
they need to find a way to settle settle
settle in a way that satisfies
the 22 individuals i'm not saying hush
money i'm not saying make it go away
quickly i'm not saying find a way to
make this disappear i'm saying stand up
take your reckoning make things right
and do it sooner rather than later
because at some point you're gonna have
to do it you may as well do it now it's
just like colonoscopy at some point
you're gonna have to do it you may as
well do it now yeah i i hear you mike i
got listen i got nothing to add there i
mean it i i didn't realize all those
specifics there but it's interesting and
again it proves to your point of why he
should settle
at playoff cap if deshaun watson plays
again do you think he'll be able to lead
a group of men given the creepiness of
the allegations against him you know my
first thought was i wasn't even gonna
read that question but then i thought
about mike vick
i mean mike vick came back
after being involved in dog fighting and
and admitting to killing dogs he
admitted to killing dogs that you know
being involved in i don't know that he
ever admitted to being the one who
strangled or electrocuted or beat the
dogs to death but he was involved in the
group that did and he admitted to being
part of that and and he came back and he
played at a high level i think if you
play at a high level that's all any of
your teammates are going to care about
whatever the outcome is whatever happens
it's over it's done and we move forward
as a team whatever team he's on
i think that he'll eventually be
accepted if he if he
if he accepts his reckoning whatever it
is makes things right i think he'll be
able to continue with his career once he
serves whatever suspension the nfl
imposes upon him he he will look like
yeah
will he be able to yes to a degree i
mean yeah there's going to be certain
guys in the locker room or in the huddle
they're really not going to care they're
just going to go man he's good
all i view him is for what i've seen and
met him and they'll be able to kind of
you know again swipe it under the rug
that way but you know it it's not like
you you you said it right a lot of these
guys too i mean they'll be guys in the
in the huddle i was on teams or
offensive linemen and things like that
they might have looked at a receiver who
was a painter like oh man i ethan hate
that guy i can't stand him that jerk and
all these type of things but it didn't
affect their play you know again it just
hey i'm going to do my job and it'll
work in the bigger picture of the team
and all of that so you don't have to
love every guy on your team and be like
that you know to make it work
he's certainly going to have to prove
himself to people and people are going
to be looking at him in the side eye
going like what kind of guy is this yeah
he's going to have a lot of that and
until
you know if he does get that opportunity
to play again to where yeah he got some
good years and and people
get to know him a little bit better and
maybe he could prove you know that he's
turned the corner of this weird phase of
his life with with this massage stuff
ultimately if you're a great player
these other things are going to fade
especially if the individuals in the
locker room believe that you did what
you had to do to make things right and
you've moved forward that's right i
think i think if he handles this all the
right way
whenever he's able to play again
whenever that may be it should be a
non-issue but uh we'll see next question
from at slaying eagles since jalen hurts
has the starting quarterback job for
this year in philadelphia what would you
say is a good season for him christopher
well i think just like you know of
course winning some football games but
not like having to win football games to
where we think they're in the playoff
hunt i wouldn't look at that as like oh
gosh he has to do that to continue to be
the starter i don't think that's
realistic i think we could bring in a
lot of great quarterbacks into
philadelphia i could tell you they're i
don't think they're going gonna end the
playoff hunt so i think what you'd want
to see from jalen hurst is again hey his
ability to make plays do those things
you know continue to grow within offense
learning different things all of that as
a leader and then ultimately the biggest
thing as we all know is just continue to
be
more of a polished passer that way you
know yes there was some really
impressive throws and he threw the ball
better than i expected him to be able to
i will say that but you know still there
there's some parts in some games where
you go that's not up to par like i
always go back to that dallas game
because there was there was some throws
and decisions in that one that are like
whoa is that a bad throw and what was
that a bad decision and all those things
so i think that's what it is just the
continued direction in the right path
show us flash as you're growing as a
passer and continue to be that playmaker
you are on the run and with deep passes
down the field and then he might have an
opportunity to solidify himself as a
starter there in philadelphia
yeah look i think this is about
stabilizing
after what happened last year steady
hand productive
win games stats don't matter it is
getting the offense to perform running
the offense executing it the way that it
needs to be executed yes getting the
team in position where they're at least
in the conversation to potentially win
the division that's a successful year
they don't have to win the division they
just have to stabilize they have to
bottom out you know this is a team
that's just been going down down down
down this year it's successful if you
get flattening and a little bit of a dip
forward right that's what he needs to do
yeah i'm with you exactly right that
kind of said you said it the right way
and you know we know we saw he he's got
some charisma about him i love the way
he answers questions in the press you
know he is all about his business and
you know even when he was asked about
carson wentz he just that's not my
business i'm just you know i'm gonna
play football and do that you know he's
got all those right intangibles it's
it's continued growth in what you're
saying and really the biggest thing is
just you know the the the continued
ability can he progress dyson people up
in the pocket with his right arm
the next question comes from a twitter
handle that sounds somewhat vaguely
familiar to me at nfl shireen i'm not
quite sure
who that may be the cowboys passed on a
defensive player to take cd lamb in
2020. if tight end kyle pitts is there
at number 10
do they pass on a defensive player again
to take him this question comes amid
reports and obviously it comes from our
own shereen williams that jerry jones
has fallen in love with kyle pitts of
course he was in love with johnny
manziel seven years ago right others in
the organization restrained him from
drafting johnny manziel but what do you
think if pitts is there at 10 assuming
he's there at 10 which may be a big
assumption what do you think the cowboys
do no
no
negative ghost rider right the pattern
is full we got enough weapons in the
pass game you got a decent tight end as
is
like that that part of your team is
pretty kind of elite like i don't know
i i just i would not agree with that
move that defense was sucky ducky last
year what do you want to say i mean you
know
there's a lot of issues across the board
they need a difference maker on the
defensive side of the ball
and again yeah i would go past rusher
you know quitty pay corey payee i'm not
sure about his last name p-a-y-e i don't
know if i'm saying it is pay right okay
good i he he would be the one that
sitting there at 10 you know
gosh take him get him off the edge in
that dan quinn defense that'll be
special or if the kid you know jalen
phillips or miami's there that would be
you know or a corner you know mike here
here's one of the really intriguing
things about the draft giraffe
at least in my eyes and i you know
listen i hear danielle jeremiah i think
he he would probably agree with this a
little bit too i always pay attention to
some of the things he says because he's
spot on but like when you look at the
draft and you look at the players not a
lot of like superstar high-end players
in this draft it's not as you know big
time as past drafts
i would argue
that really
of out take the quarterbacks out that
two of the five best players in the
draft
caleb farley virginia tech jalen
phillips who to me is the best pass
rusher in the draft and a physical freak
they have medical things right like
caleb
farley is is one of the best corners
i've ever seen coming out of college and
evaluated he just had back surgery you
know the jaylen phillips is he reminds
me of jpp or julius peppers and one of
those type of guys coming off the edge
and
he's got the concussion issue and
retired from football for a year because
of that that to me is also just i'm
sorry to take us off task here a little
bit but just a very intriguing aspect of
this kind of weird draft with the
quarterbacks in the top 10 and
everything like that you know to add all
along with this
you make a great point and one of the
problems this year because there wasn't
a scouting combine no centralized
opportunity to get medical information
and some of that stuff
hard to come by agents
not necessarily willing to be as
forthcoming as they would need to be
because they want to get their guy
drafted as high as possible and then the
team can worry about the medical issues
later but that is part of the problem
here and that
beyond the issues of some teams didn't
play much football some guys didn't play
at all no scouting combine on-field
workouts the value of the scouting
combine is the medical and they don't
have that man this year to the extent
that they normally do that is a problem
at least last year they had that because
we had the combine before the world
turned upside down so that's going to
make a lot of this
crap shoot
uh
something that will cause
teams to yeah say awards that's crazy
right it's all said and done right uh
another question and uh these have been
very good we thank everyone out there
who have uh contributed
kellen monde this is from jim balboni
chris mentioned calaman to the patriots
of steelers on his podcast do i agree
that this is realistic well well i've
been listening to chris so i agree it's
real i think it's realistic i i think
that kellen mond has been the guy who's
overlooked all the talk is trevor
lawrence zach wilson trey lance justin
fields mac jones you never hear about
kellen mod you've got him at number four
you've got him ahead of lance and fields
yeah all it takes is one team to feel
that way and this guy's a a top not top
10 but top 20 pick i i look for the
router i look at him like that certainly
i do i think he's a first round
quarterback i don't even i don't mean
and again i can line them up against
other a lot of other quarterbacks over
the last five 10 years and go
what like what did you see in that guy's
film and you thought he was a first
rounder
and then you watch this guy's film and
you don't think he's a first rounder i
don't understand that i don't you know
decision making great like elite arm
elite a lead in all aspects it really is
i will go back to what i said from the
start i his only issue is i wish he
would just relax with the ball a little
bit and scramble a little bit more
that's an easy fix
that's an easy fix
his issues are way easier to fix to me
than trey lance who hasn't really even
played a lot of football and i think has
a somewhat of a question in or a hitch
in his throwing motion and the same with
justin fields to where i would just go
man kel and mon it's it's kind of a
clean slate
you know that's where i i just you you
can mold this guy to be a really you
know special pocket passer and he's
going to be able to make big time plays
with his legs here you know i'm just i'm
shocked by it it's been three years of
really good play at a school where he
hasn't had big end talent around him
and he dices up sec defenses weekly and
last year was phenomenal i just don't
get it that's the crazy thing to me
about the draft sometimes just how some
guys get hyped and other guys don't in
certain years in the same year all that
it just uh it annoys me sometimes
yeah and look i agree with you i uh uh
and he's gonna be a very intriguing
prospect especially the more of a run
that there is
on quarterbacks at the top it's gonna
elevate that that's the one thing you
want to see if you're an agent who
represents
a quarterback you want quarterbacks to
be drafted quickly quickly quickly
receiver you want go go go get them off
the board because then my guy pumps up
the list to the best remaining players
at the position and even though teams
say they're going to take the best
available player regardless of position
their needs influence
which way they go when they evaluate the
best available so the closer your guy is
to the top of the remaining at his
position the better chance he has of
getting draft
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports